yeah people are asking about like your
sound stage and like how that'll work
and this is i guess specifically nana p
asking how the sound stage will work are
you
branching out to a circle of friends or
only open it for creators in la
like what yeah are you opposed to
opening up to other people what's your
plan with it
uh that's a great question uh and i'll
answer it like this
it'll be in phases so the reason we got
it is because i'm sure you know
booking locations is expensive and the
bigger the space is you pay you know
sometimes five thousand dollars a day
right that's an insane cost so with our
sound stage
you know we were looking at we were just
outgrowing like my personal office is
was basically just for podcasts there's
not much room to shoot anything else in
there
and my business partner brennan his
space was getting too small for the
stuff that we were doing
so you know we went out looking for a
space so that when we shoot a movie
or a unscripted series we can have a
full green screen because you know we
have to go
rent a full green scheme uh green screen
white site
that's 1500 a day now we have that
in here now we can help shoot podcasts
and all that type of stuff
but to answer your question initially
it's just going to be for our stuff
because
you know we got to you know use it there
first
but eventually i don't know if it'll
ever be like youtube space la
where you just come in and shoot there
because that requires insurance at
supreme levels requires like crew and
people to man that
but at least shooting things for the app
you know that we believe in it'll be
used for that um
in the future when i get into
philanthropic philanthropic areas
i'd love to get a space that is like
youtube space
where you can just come in and shoot and
the cameras and stuff are there uh
that's definitely something i want to do
i don't know if it'll be this
specific place where we're actually
shooting and using it there if that
makes sense
yeah how i saw this question as like the
comments keep popping up but like
someone was asking about like
what is your 10-year plan and like is
your is your career
fairly like planned out like are you do
you have it kind of in stages
i couldn't first of all joel i couldn't
even have
thought from this year the beginning of
this year to where we are this year
never would have thought that like mind
you so i don't know if you know this we
we got kicked out of our first office
because of racism we call that the
racism office
um we got kicked out in february this
year
we got our our current podcast studio in
february
march happens a doggone global pandemic
shuts all that down i'm on tour i got 70
dates
me into here did i don't know eight
cities
so i'm sitting there march 15th you know
22nd hearing from my agent like yeah
all your april is cancelled and all your
maze cancelled and june's not looking
good either
so to go from that to creating keep your
distance
and and uh the idea to get an app
also happened during this time and then
being able to have the resources to go
out and get
i can't even couldn't fathom this
these 12 months so i wouldn't dare
disrespect god to think about where 10
years could be i could be
a household name on forbes magazine
right
but my goal all my goal it's only broken
down to i want to make great content
for people to see and get opportunities
for others
if that's my app if that's netflix
saying we love you so much we're gonna
give you a hundred million dollars
and i'm gonna be like nah man a hundred
jillion
that's what i'm talking about like i
don't even know what that could be so
i won't disrespect god by trying to see
how that looks practically all i'll say
is i hope that
in 10 years i am still holding true to
making content that i want to see
making content that my audience wants to
see and giving other creators
a chance and giving them opportunities
that's
really all i want to do for the rest of
my life
i love that i love how clear that vision
is though the intent behind what you're
doing
yeah yeah that part is clear as today
and honestly in some ways i've been
doing that since i was back in
washington we were doing plays
and not making a dime we were still
giving people an opportunity to act in
tacoma
who there was no there was not many
opportunities to act in a play in tacoma
so i'm really just doing the same thing
i've been doing like even the sketches
you see
we've you see look at my old youtube
we've been doing music videos we just
did a we did a capri sun song
10 years ago i just didn't have the
resources i have now to actually make it
look good
yeah i've been doing music forever i
just did it on instagram with the music
playing out of my computer
now because of my business partners and
you know where i'm in life i can really
just
make it look nice but in some ways i'm
i'm doing what i've always been doing
you know what i'm saying i love it hey
hot brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips